christoph poschenrieder würdiger
safranski herzlich willkommen den
sternstunden auto schopenhauer ist ja
vielen bekannt als pessimist aus
frauenhaus sogar wie kam es dazu dass
sie sich ausgerechnet eine solche figur
ausgesucht haben für ihren ersten roman
herr poschenrieder also jedenfalls war
es nicht die absicht dieses bild wieder
umzukehren dass ich fühle mich nach
erfreulich dass der image berater
schopenhauers ich habe eine geschichte
gesehen in seiner persönlichen
geschichte und die dachte ich wäre
auszubauen wenn im nebeneffekt der alte
miesepeter schopenhauer in
anführungszeichen ein bisschen besser
aussieht bin ich schon zufrieden
auf dem missetäter werden wir sicher
noch zu sprechen kommen vielleicht
zuerst noch eine frage an sie herr
safranski
sie eröffnen ja ihre biografie über
schopenhauer mit dem satz dieses buch
ist eine liebeserklärung an die
philosophie
ich gehe das denn zusammen
pessimistische philosophie liebes
erklären ja so geht das ihm zusammen
weil philosophie auch etwas ist wo man
es dann doch in der wirklichkeit aus
hält auch wenn man sonst eigentlich ein
düsteres bild von der wirklichkeit hat
und das liebe ich an der philosophie
dass sie einen besseren zustand oder
show bauer sagt ein besseres bewusstsein
eröffnet
außerdem ist es auch eine
liebeserklärung an die ganze geniale
zeit um 1800 und etwas später wo
schopenhauer ja groß wird wo
schopenhauer seine philosophische
inspirationen empfängt und das ist eine
zeit die philosophie hat niemals so
geblüht jedenfalls im europäischen
maßstab wie damals in dieser zeit das
sagte auch ein bisschen der untertitel
ihres buches shoppen haben uns die
wilden jahre der philosophie was war
denn daran so wird das will damit waren
daran war dass das man entdeckt hat dass
man ein schöpferisches ich hat dass man
ein subjekt
vorher wurde von ordnung er gedacht da
wurde vom über subjektiven her gedacht
auch vom religiösen und jetzt auf einmal
hoppla ist es eine neue lust einig zu
sein
das war die geheime botschaft dieser
philosophie des deutschen idealismus
damals darauf wären wir ja noch kommen
die show bauer allerdings quer dazu
stehen genau bedienen wir zuerst
vielleicht ein bisschen über diese
person arthur schopenhauer zu sprechen
wir werden diese person als er ist vor
150 jahren gestorben das gibt uns anders
auch für diese sendung wer war arthur
schopenhauer
also ich meine man muss sich klar machen
als low power 17 88 geboren und er
wächst auf eigentlich in der goethe zeit
noch er ist eigentlich ein mensch des
frühen 19ten jahrhunderts mit seiner
philosophie lebt dann aber bis 1860 und
gerät noch in die zeit der fotografie
deswegen haben wir diese alten bilder
von schopenhauer ja immer nur als alten
mann diese alten fotos aber er ist
eigentlich ein junger mann also viel
entwickelt und entwickelt sie eigentlich
wie soll man sagen ganz auf sich
gestellt jenseits der universität er ist
ein quereinsteiger in die philosophie er
hat vermögen der vater war kaufmann
da hat er geerbt und er wie er sagte er
konnte für die philosophie leben er
musste nicht von ihr leben und da hat er
auch viel spott ausgegossen über die
kollegen die dann an den universitäten
lassen und ihn ignoriert haben ja und da
hat er gesagt nun ja so eine katheder
philosophie die muss mich natürlich
abbringen war ja insgesamt auch nicht
gerade eine einfache person lehrer von
ihren roman ja mit einer szene wo er
geradezu schäumt vor wut ich glaube ich
der erste satz des buches heißt dass
schopenhauer war wütend was hat es mit
dieser geschichte auf sich das ist
fiktion allerdings
er hatte ja ein problem mit seinem
verleger nicht nur mit seinem verleger
mit dem besonders der sollte dieses buch
drucken zu einem vereinbarten termin hat
das aber versäumt sollte september
rauskommen kam aber erst im januar des
folgenden jahres und da gab es einen
briefwechsel zwischen den beiden der
sehr pointiert war dann auch damit
geendet hat das der verleger ein
prophetisches wort sprach für mich ich
hoffe nur dass ich am werke keine
makulatur drücke was dann allerdings
auch vorerst mal eingetreten ist dieser
wütende schopenhauer ist dass
allgemeiner gemütszustand bei ihm am
ende ja allgemein einen pessimisten
typischen charakter noch ein g zu
negativ im prinzip wohl zurückhaltend
also es gibt beschreibungen von seiner
mutter die auch dass ihm vorhält dass er
bei ihren gesellschaften zu denen noch
heute regelmäßig kam in weimar am rande
stand und damit ziemlich finsterer miene
da zugeschaut hat aber sich nicht
eingebracht hat also einerseits
zurückhaltend aber wenn bestimmte
schwellen überschritten wurden bei ihm
dann konnte ziemlich explodieren muss
man wohl annehmen und anschwellen das
war vor allem seine philosophie da der
schock mal das muss man sich schon klar
machen er entwickelt seine philosophien
doch sein hauptwerk bis zum jahre 1818
da ist dann die welt als wille und
vorstellung fertig und wie der shop
mauer veröffentlicht das dann bei
brokers und glaubt dann doch jetzt kommt
der große auftritt und er muss bemerken
es ist sein auftritt aber kein halt
gekommen keiner liest und als er dann
nach berlin geht und dort vorlesungen
hält und seine vorlesung stunden just
auf die zeit liegt wo hegel auch nicht
der könig der philosophie in berlin ja
kommt auch keiner
und dieser schopenhauer muss es ertragen
ohne einen auftritt gehabt zu haben
wieder abzutreten
und es dauert 30 jahre ist eigentlich
die richtige reaktion einsetzt und das
ist eine lange zeit und schopenhauer hat
diese zeit eigentlich nur ausgehalten
würde ich mal sagen seelisch weil er den
grundsatz sich so also da es sich im
grundsatz so erklärt hat die wahrheit
braucht lange bis sie in die köpfe der
gewöhnlichen menschen hinein kommen und
deswegen wenn ich so eine lange zeit
warten muss bis in den köpfen es ist
dasselbe eine bestätigung meiner
philosophie
ja und er hat gewissermaßen aus seiner
philosophie die kraft gezogen das
skandalon zu ertragen dass sie solange
nicht akzeptiert worden ist und in
dieser gang eine ganze lange zeit
brauchte er gelassenheit
er war auch immer mal wieder wütend so
ist es herrlich die schopenhauer schon
fünf predigten gegen die anderen
philosophen zu lesen
das sind das größte das ist ein ganz
großer ereignisse der polemik in der
prosa und der deutschen prosa des frühen
19ten jahrhunderts nun muss man ja aber
doch sagen ich habe nichts wissen so
geschildert dass er eigentlich ganz
zufrieden fast schon gewartet hat dem
stuhl von muss halt warten bis die leute
begreifen aber sie zitieren nämlich auch
eine wunderbare stelle was schopenhauer
sich notiert hat es als er das erste mal
sein hauptwerk in händen hielt und da
steht geschrieben möglich strom wie ihr
wollt gebärden des werkes leben könnt
ihr nicht gefährden aufhalten könnte ist
nimmermehr vernichten ein denkmal wird
die nachwelt mehr errichten also schon
relativ selbstbewusst unterwegs der
bisschen über 30-jährige schopenhauer
der war immer wahnsinnig selbstbewusst
und er hatte nie ein zweifel daran dass
er etwas großartiges vollbracht hatte
das problem war nur dass er
man merkt es auch in der vorrede zudem
zu dem hauptwerk er geht voran und geht
auch immer wieder einen schritt zurück
er geht nach berlin er will vorlesungen
halten und er macht es genau zu der zeit
zu der regel liest ja es sieht immer so
aus als würde sozusagen sein unglück
auch immer ein bisschen herausfordern ja
um diese prüfung die seinem werk in der
öffentlichkeit vor stünde wenn es denn
gelesen wurde zu vermeiden ich mir ist
das nicht ganz klar warum er das macht
aber es kommt mehrfach vorbringen
welche rolle spielte der in dem ganzen
die familie
sie hatten schon erwähnt vater kaufmann
dann gibt es ja noch seine mutter die
ganz berühmte johanna schopenhauer ja er
erlebt wie die mutter johanna ist ein
kapitel wirklich für sich
die schopenhauer erlebt wie die mutter
berühmt wird und auf lebt nachdem der
vater tot ist sie war um einiges jünger
als ihr mann also art durch vater und
natur hat sich dann doch immer auf die
seite des vaters gestellt und eigentlich
wollte er bei der mutter die nach dem
tod des vaters den ersatz patriarchen
spielen mir hat also das war eigentlich
den ehrgeiz und die haben die beiden
haben nun auch ganz groß gestritten und
es ist ergreifend zu sehen wie die
johanna die mutter zu ihm sagt ja ich
möchte dass du glücklich wird und ich
will auch alles dafür tun aber ich
brauche nicht zeuge davon zu sein bleibt
mehr vom leibe eigentlich dachte das
bleibt mir vom leibe
und weil shoppen aber nun ihr sie
glaubte erzielen zu müssen
so kann man mit johanna ganz gut
verstehen dass sie sich den shop mal vom
leibe gehalten
nun war aber johanna in weimar nach er
war ein gesellschaftlicher mittelpunkt
und dagegen goethe ein und aus und
goethe hielt große stücke auf die
johanna ganz einfach weil sie auch die
christiane vulpius eingeladen hat
goethes frau damals inzwischen schon an
gerichte frau und die übrige weimarer
gesellschaft rümpfte die nase und wollte
sie nicht einladen und johanna lud sie
ein und johanna hatte noch den starken
spruch das ja wenn goethe ihr seine hand
gibt dann kann ich jedoch wenigstens ein
tee geben ja und so konnte sie dann also
tee trinken weil johanna und arthur
konnte goethe dort treffen als zaungast
und später dann verbuschung wieder
erwähnte das selbstbewusstsein schoben
art da gibt es dann schon mal ein
exempel
schopenhauer der junge schopenhauer
entwickler also entwickelt auch eine
farben theorie im umgang mit goethe der
auch gerade an seiner farben theorie
entwickelte und der junge schüler den
meister gegenüber signalisiert er schob
mauer habe die farben theorie von goethe
eigentlich erst vervollkommnet also da
will der schüler gleich den lehrer
belehren
schopenhauer bewundert goethe und
besonderen lebensende und goethe sagt
werden gibt zu verstehen aber jetzt hier
ist es los da hat eine grenze übertreten
das großartige an schopenhauer ist auch
dann durch diese zurückweisung
er entwickelt keinem augenblick
ressentiment oder neid oder ist
irgendwie zerstört nein er ist überhaupt
nicht zerstört er versteht ein dicht an
den goethe dass der abstand will also
anders als so andere figuren die goethe
umschwärmt
in derselben zeit hölderlin gegen fast
kaputt daran dass goethe ihn nicht ihn
auf abstand hielt ja oder kleist gegen
kaputt daran
schopenhauer mit diesem gottlob soliden
selbstbewusstsein gegen seinen weg geht
spielt auch eine große rolle in ihrem
roman insofern dass schopenhauer ja eine
einladungskarte von goethe hat und mit
der auf diese italienische reise geht
sie haben ja aus diesem detail der
biografie von schopenhauer einen roman
geschaffen
können sie uns ein bisschen mehr davon
verraten was passiert da diese
empfehlungs karte hat goethe dem dem
schopenhauer geschickt von k s band aus
die die forschung ist sich nicht
hundertprozentig sicher dass da wirklich
an waren auf der karte stand in die
karte ist er verschwunden
die beiden ist der ja dass das der große
skandal dichter des frühen 19ten
jahrhunderts popstar 1 1 die tat bei dem
nicht nur das interessiert was er auf
die tierischen gebiet leistet sondern
vor allem auch was er so im
gesellschaftlichen leistet da gab es
einige hervorragende ausrutscher der
basis jedenfalls europaweit bekannt
berüchtigt ein idol für junge menschen
vor allem frauen
es liegt eine gewisse ironie in der
geschichte dass diese empfehlung von
goethe an ebendiesen berlin ausgestellt
worden sein soll
was wie gesagt ich kann sicher ist also
der grüblerische zurückhaltend der
arthur schopenhauer wirklich kein mensch
der auf partys ging zusammenzubringen
mit dieser mit diesem diesem mann der
also damals in venedig lebt und den
karneval liebste und gar nicht mehr
aufhörte mit karneval und sich dabei
allerdings schon ziemlich übernommen
hatte jedenfalls diese geschichte spielt
damit dass schopenhauer eben seine nach
der vollendung seines hauptwerkes
bisschen urlaub machen möchte und nach
italien reist und sich von goethe der
die gesagt ein freund der familie war
diese diese empfehlung holt und dann
eben losfährt und möglicherweise eine
für ihn großartige begegnung gelegenheit
verpasst ähnlich wir im grunde die
gelegenheit aus der begegnung mit goethe
etwas zu machen auch verpasst hat sind
in dem er den mann verprellt hat der
hätte helfen können
zu diesem zeitpunkt dürfte seine also
das hätte seiner philosophie am anfang
sicherlich einen starken schub gegeben
wenn der noch gutes patronat gehabt
hätte
gegen vielleicht jetzt ein bisschen auf
die philosophie von schopenhauer einsam
jahren gestört zu personen mich
interessiert der titel des buches sie
nennen ihr buch herr poschenrieder die
welt ist im kopf wenn man das buch liest
dann wird einem klar das ist sozusagen
das programm vom schopenhauers
philosophie
inwiefern ist dann die welt im kopf das
spielt auf die auf die erkenntnis lehrer
an die schopenhauer vertritt da ist ein
im gefolge kannst sagt er ja dass alle
erkenntnis die wir haben können durch
die sinne vermittelt ist und sich erst
durch die tätigkeit des intellekts der
ein produkt des gehirns ist im grunde im
kopf bildet und diese kleine szene aus
der dann dieser titelzeile schafft
stammt es ist der versuch das mal in ein
paar worten zu erklären
für jedermann
ja vollkommen richtig nun heißt sein
hauptwerk die welt als wille und
vorstellung die welt vorstellung die
welt ist im kopf vorstellen wobei dieser
begriff vorstellung wirklich alles um
schreibt was in unserem kopf ist und da
beißt die maus den faden nicht ab was
wir von der welt erfahren fahren wir
natürlich über unseren denkt und
wahrnehmung separat für das war damals
die ganz große frage die gekannt da noch
aufgeworfen hat ja aber wenn das alles
durch unsere verarbeitungsmechanismen
hindurch geht ja was ist denn und wie es
denn die wirklichkeit selbst ohne dass
sie durch gefiltert wird euch unser
mannen separat und das hatte dann kann
das ding an sich genannt das war nichts
unanständiges jahr sondern das war die
welt hinter unseren vorstellungen mehr
und in diesem problem horizont ja agiert
der junge schopenhauer und macht etwas
was eigentlich so atemberaubend ist
sagte ok wenn wir nicht wissen was die
welt sonst noch ist außer dass sie von
uns vorgestellte ja was haben wir für
ein anhaltspunkt und da sagt er
man ging immer nach draußen man muss in
sich gehen und da spürt man eine
lebendigkeit er nennt es dann will das
ist das ist die leid nah erfahrung das
ist unsere verkörperte existenz das ist
die wirklichkeit 1 und die wirklichkeit
2 ist dann was wir daraus machen und so
sagt er die heiße zone der wirklichkeit
ist unsere im eigenen körper verkörperte
will dann sagt er und damit das
eigentlich schon die ganze philosophie
dargestellt sagte wir müssen davon
ausgehen dass was wir im inneren als
wille erfahren als trieb als begehren
als lust als schmerz dass das auch in
der übrigen natur drinnen
warum sollte es nur bei mir drin stecken
steckt überall drinnen und deswegen nach
der der grund die heiße zone des der
existenz ist der wille und die
vorstellung ist das licht das da auf
gesteckt worden ist um die dinge dann
noch zu sehen ja und das ergibt um das
sozusagen die pointe ist mit diesem
gedanken beim leid zu beginn seine
philosophie beim trip beginnt was man
nennen könnte die biologische wende in
der philosophie ist es immer über den
menschen nachgedacht morgen ist vom
geist her gedacht worden oder von gott
klar und schopenhauer denkt den menschen
von der anime lied er er rückt den
menschen im grunde ins tierreich und
manchmal sogar ein pudel war manchmal
lieber als der mensch und wenn er der
kugel trudelt ihn ärgerte dann schimpfte
er ihn du mensch und das sollte kein
kampf kompliment sein ja also die
biologische wende in der in der
philosophie vollzieht sich mit
schopenhauer und da sind wir weil wir
vorher ja über die über das verkannt
werden dass ignoriert werden gesprochen
haben
da haben wir das betriebsgeheimnis
dieser lorants das kam zu früh in dieser
zeit hegel hegel schelling schicht wie
sie alle heißen diese großen koryphäen
das war die grandiose philosophie des
geistes da ging es vom geist aus bis in
die der geist ist auch in der natur und
schopenhauer sagt der geistig der natur
alliierte den geist und die anderen
vergeistigten die natur so und deswegen
das kann zu früh so was heute man gar
nicht wenn ich sie richtig verstanden
habe sie haben auch emanuel kommt
erwähnt
großen philosophen der aufklärung ist ja
auch vorhin haben alle diese leute also
hegel fichte schelling kommt weiter
einziger job und auch aber er hat sie
sozusagen eine andere richtung getrieben
in diese biologische wende hinein man
kann ganz einfach sagen
er nimmt wie die anderen auch die frage
nach dem ding an sich auf die anderen
sagen das ding an sich also die
wirklichkeit selbst ist eigentlich das
inkognito gottes und schopenhauer sagt
dass es das inkognito des leides das
heißt er die diametral andere antwort
gibt er als als als die übrigen und
deswegen muss er 30 jahren machen
deswegen als die diesel auch wunderbare
idealistische philosophie ausgetobt
hatte und als 48 die revolutionen in
deutschland da gescheitert war und als
so einen kater als stimmung aufkam und
auch nicht zu vergessen die
naturwissenschaften immer weiter
angestiegen waren in ihrer bedeutung da
bemerkte man den eremiten in frankfurt
ja und da kann man da liefen sie ihm
dann die bude ein und guckten wie einem
englischen hof zum mittag gegessen hat
ja mal war der philosoph der erfahrung
sind immer bei dem an was ist erfahrbar
was was kann man jetzt direkt wissen hat
nie vom vom begriff ausgearbeitet also
die genannte das meistens dann hole
begriffe was die anderen verwendeten
sondern sagte sie jemand über die fohlen
philosophie anfängt muss man mal in sich
hinein gucken und dann wird sich der
rest schon ergeben
dieses in sich hinein gucken ist ja auch
sehr interessant was viele nicht wissen
dass sich schopenhauer sehr beschäftigt
hat mit buddhistischen und
hinduistischen schriften
was hat es auf sich das ist eben das
zweite große kapitel seiner philosophie
jetzt haben mal über die biologische
wende gesprochen jetzt haben wir über
dieses dieses in sich hinein gucken und
sich selber als verkauft hatte als leib
zu erfahren als villa als trieb grund
usw
jetzt gehört ja dazu dass wenn man so
auf den menschen blickt man ja auch
wiederum nicht überrascht ist wie der
geschichts lauf aussieht und stechen ja
mensch es sich wechselseitig ein wolf ja
und im grunde kommt es darauf an den
menschen zu zähmen
das ist eigentlich diese diese
vorstellen uns eigentlich sind wir
raubtiere zivilisierte raubtiere und der
und das raubtier wesen blickt immer
wieder durch das ist eigentlich der der
blick von schober und jetzt ist ihm aber
auch klar dass es auch eine innere
erfahrung dass das beste was ist der
mensch zustande bringen kann ist wenn er
in der lage ist wie auch immer also
dieses dieser ego diesen egoistischen
trieb an dieser front zu richten ansicht
zu halten sich zum ziemlich nur sich zu
zählen sondern was er dann nennt die
verneinung des willens
im extremfall der blick dann auf die
großen gestalten der askese des
verzichtes der selbstüberwindung ja er
blickt in dieser weise darauf wie auf
hochleistungs athleten der der
selbstüberwindung auf jesus auf butter
auf franz von assisi usw dachte aber
auch immer dazu er selber als kein high
naja er selber ist kein buddha von
frankfurt ja aber die philosophie ist in
diesem abrüstungs programm schon mal ein
ganz wichtiger schritt
er entwickelt also von dem programmpunkt
es sich zurücknehmen entwickelt er auch
als mit als einer der ersten entwickelt
er einen brückenschlag zur zur östlichen
weisheit zum buddhismus und diese art
von atheistischer religiosität gemeinsam
das ist ein aspekt wo ich denke wo
schopenhauer noch ganz schön gerade dort
ganz schön aktuell ist denn das brauchen
wir darauf später noch zu sprechen
in ihrem roman später ist eine große
rolle bleiben wir noch ein bisschen bei
diesem punkt dieser buddhismus
hinduismus was zieht er daraus
schopenhauer
das hängt mit dem willens begriff
zusammen dieser wille über den fall
gesprochen haben das ist ja das
universal dynamischen universal prinzip
verschoben aber er ist überall er es in
allen steckt da drin und der führte für
das alltägliche leben des menschen eben
dazu dass das der sich bewegt sich
gedrängt fühlt und auch bedrängt fühlt
von allen möglichen das werden irgendwie
alle möglichen dinge vorgegaukelt das
ist dann die rede von motiven und der
trick worauf es gerade auch schon
hingewiesen wurde ist dieses beständige
drängen und gedrängt werden durch dieses
im prinzip prinzip das wild prinzip
finden in der willens verneinung sich da
raus zu halten
in der ultima ratio heißt dass man würde
zu einem maskierten werden was natürlich
für die meisten leute ist nicht wirklich
eine option ist in meinem buch kommt so
eine kleine szene vor
brauchte ein opium zeichen und erst mal
erwähnt habe sicher in kopenhagen war
der erste der das wirklich eine
europäische philosophie integriert hat
und was daraus gemacht hat ich weiß gar
nicht genau wie es entdeckt hat so stück
für stück als seinen aufzeichnungen aus
dieser zeit kann man das gar nicht so
genau nachverfolgen ist integriert wurde
aber es erscheint in seinem werk
erscheint sehr sehr überzeugend und er
hat sehr begrüßt und wohl das wirklich
als entdeckung gefeiert siehe da ist
jemand da ist ein ganzes philosophisches
gedanken system da die so ähnlich denken
wie ich es ist nicht der erste der das
bringt allerdings hat er ist natürlich
wenn ich das richtig verstehe da ist
dieses ständige drängen
dieser wille die ein stück weit auch ein
bisschen belästigt so weit kommt an die
fragen belästigt haben belästigt es bei
schopenhauer der wille sozusagen das
heißt der pessimismus ist eine
pessimistische philosophie wird immer
gesagt wird er daher dass das mit diesem
ständigen wollen habe das war etwas zu
tun und dann wäre der diese auslese die
überwindung des pessimismus oder die
muss man sich das glaube ich nicht
pessimist schopenhauer ist eigentlich
ein pessimist weiter keine
philosophische optimist sein will dass
das kann man sagt man heute nicht mit
einem mit dem heutigen sprachgebrauch
verwechseln truppen aber es nicht jeden
morgen aufgestanden hat gesagt oh dass
wird heute schon wieder nix also das ist
kein kein persönlicher pessimisten ist
sondern da sagte in diesem weltenlauf
wie wir ihn sehen liegt kein heil das
geht auch nicht gut aus das heißt ein
bisschen der verwechslung wenn die
meisten leute hören schopenhauer und
pessimisten hier interessiert mich nicht
die verstehen da an den pessimisten
falsch also vollkommen richtig passen
sagt man muss man versteht sein
pessimismus nur jetzt im gegensatz zu
dem damals sehr mächtigen optimismus der
da eine eine vorstellung war das der
geschichts prozess besonders jetzt bei
hegel dass das ja dann so und in der
nachfolge marx und so weiter dass der
geschichts prozess eine logik hat die
auf eine höhere entwicklung und vor
allem ein gelingen im sinne des glücks
abzielt das war das war die sozusagen
die haupt die heerstraße des denkens und
da sagt guck mal das ist ein
riesengroßer selbstbetrug er sagt nicht
es wird immer schlechter
erst dann nicht in diesem sinne fatal
ist sondern eigentlich sagt als immer
dasselbe affen rennen los auf einem
neuen technischen niveau es geht im kern
darum um selbstbehauptung um egoismus um
heute würden wir sagen nun konsum auf
immer größerer stufe 1 laufend im
hamsterrad ja es gibt nicht ein
übergeordnetes gesamtziel auf das man
läuft der wille das in deine
ausdrucksweise
was will der wille der wille will sich
selbst er will mehr er will einfach nur
mehr
und weil das alle wollen ja gibt es eben
auch ein kampf um die knappen ressourcen
das ist das bild das er von der
geschichte entwirft das hat also nichts
mit pessimismus im sinne wie gesagt von
fatalismus zu tun sondern der
zurückweisung zu einer heimlichen
theologie der geschichte in der form der
theologie dass die geschichte eben ein
ziel ein optimum hat auch dass sie läuft
da sagte alles und sind alles selbst
bedruckt werden würde dem dem optimisten
wenn dann mal einer käme würde er
anbieten hin weil durch sämtliche
lazarette und die schlachtfelder dieser
welt zu führen um mal zu zeigen wie
diese wirklich aussieht zu zeigen wie
diese angeht ist sozusagen diese
angebliche beste aller welten
er ist da schopenhauer ist immer einer
der beschreibt und der nicht vorschreibt
sondern er sagt das wird besser werden
oder schlechter werden sagt so wie es
ist wird es auch wahrscheinlich bleiben
insofern könnte man sagen ist
schopenhauer topmodern also dieses
beschreiben das hamsterrad es sozusagen
dieses konsumverhalten um dann der
versuchte auszubrechen könnte man sagen
der würde sich geradezu eigenen sohn 10
buddhistisches seminar für manager
daher eignet sich also viele da werden
ja auch buddhismus seminare angeboten
und ein bisschen 10 und taoismus ist für
jeden banker offenbar ganz wichtig und
gelassenheit zu lernen und das kann ja
anders meinen das kann man mit allem
machen
festzuhalten ist eigentlich schopenhauer
munter dazu sich selbst etwas zu machen
und dass dieses aus sich selbst machen
dass das auf jeden fall nicht auf der
ebene des immer mehr haben wollen liegen
kann ja wir haben im buch ja auch diese
geschichte mit schopenhauers vermögen
erwähnt ja da lässt sich das ganz schön
zeigen mit dem haben so bauer hat sein
vermögen das er geerbt hat mit
erheblicher klugheit verteidigt ja zum
teil sogar den handlungs ja warum
er wusste ganz genau nicht als konsum
ist sozusagen sondern er wusste dieses
vermögen das er von seinem vater geerbt
hat das erlaubt ihm eine philosophische
existenz deswegen konnte er für die
philosophie leben und musste nicht vorn
ihr leben das erlaubte ihm seine
freiheit und diese freiheit braucht er
um und bestochen durch irgendwelche
interessen dahinter ja immer geld
interessen stehen zum ungestörten und
möglichst klar und möglichst objektiv
vielleicht auch gnadenlos und und
illusionär über die verhältnisse
nachzudenken so ging er mit seinem
als quelle der freiheit
wobei ich habe power zeigt in seinem
hauptwerk diesen weg zum asketen auf
also diese überwindung dieses drums und
gedrängt science dass man empfinden kann
das ist dass es natürlich die harte tour
die weder er noch sonst jemand oder
diejenigen heilen noch gerade heiligen
noch gerade mal erreicht haben es gibt
da noch den späteren schopenhauer der
verbindung von den aphorismen zur
lebensweisheit der zeigt der praktische
wege auf also die beiden sozusagen seine
philosophisch entspanntes leben auch im
alltag führen könnte wir sehen in der
einblendung auch ein bild dieses älteren
schopenhauers dabei dann auch sehr
erfolgreich mit diesen aphorismen haben
ihn ja die leute fast schon die bude
eingerannt uns ein bisschen ist ob
zusagen machte er denn das setzt sich so
stieß dazu leben ganz menschlich
einerseits gegen die leute dann auch auf
die nerven
er konnte er leute sowieso nur in der
halbdistanz ertragen alles was zu dicht
dran war das war unangenehm für ihn also
das hat ihn dann schon auch gefallen
natürlich jetzt die anerkennung dann zu
finden
er sagte so immer wieder der nil ist bei
kairo angekommen
endlich haben die leute gemerkt er hat
ist das mündungsgebiet seiner
philosophie geraten das hat ihm schon
auch geschmeichelt und das war für ihn
eine genugtuung
aber er hatte sich ja auch nicht
vorzuwerfen dass er nach dem
publikumsgeschmack sich gerichtet hat
sondern er hat nicht das publikum
gesucht sondern er hat sich vom publikum
am ende finden lassen
und das gibt schon eine solide
selbstbewusst werden jetzt wird mich
noch interessieren wenn wir von dieser
überwindung des willens gesprochen haben
ging es ja vorhin um askese eine
wichtige rolle spielt aber schopenhauer
auch kunst musik insbesondere wie orden
die das ein dass es sozusagen die
vorstufe zum asketen tun also das ist
die
der asket hat sozusagen den willen auf
dauer überwunden und in der
kunstbetrachtung und in der content und
kontemplation des schönen können wir
diese momente die der asket dann
dauerhaft genießt können wir können wir
die kurzzeitig gewesen das sind diese
momente in dem sich der wille überwinden
lässt indem man der reinen betrachtung
liegt und nicht das gefühl mehr hat von
dem was uns da vor augen steht zb
gedrängt zu sein oder hingezogen zu
werden insbesonders hat man das gefühl
dann nach schopenhauer beim genuss der
musik
da gibt es ja dann wiederum der stelle
die weniger schön ist in ihrem buch da
sind wir nämlich beim frauenhaus
angelangt wo er sagt die frauen die
könnten eigentlich zeit große fr wenn
die mal vorgeben sich für musik zu
interessieren oder für kunst was ist
denn damit damit darüber müssen
vielleicht auch noch sprechen da aber
achtung für schopenhauer was ist dass
diese serie hausverwalter dem in den
romanen von christoph poschenrieder
da wird gerne liebesgeschichte erzählt
ja und das ist ja auch vollkommen
richtig
der schopenhauer hat auch mal gedacht ja
mit den weibern weibern mit den weibern
daher hat absolut er er würde ja
vielleicht auch noch mal anders denken
wenn sie nur hätte haben woher ihn
hätten haben wollen ja also es ist ganz
unverhohlen dass da auch eine ganze
menge frustration natürlich auch mit
dabei ist dann auch die erfahrung mit
der mutter usw
also es gibt da für seine
nicht sehr freundlichen äußerungen über
die frauen gibt es gewissermaßen
biografische hintergründe aber es ist
also wirklich mal als tt ich versuche es
an meinem buch auch ein bisschen
darzustellen
es ist hängt aber natürlich auch
zusammen mit seiner mit seinem
verhältnis zur sexualität sexualität war
für ihn natürlich natur trieb sehr klar
ist es ja auch ja und natur trieb und
ein natur trieb er in seiner sicht
besonders schwer zu zivilisieren ist
also da war für ihn in deiner sicht da
fährt die natur in uns mit uns selbst
schlitten ja also da sind wir eigentlich
vollkommen machtlos dass der
staatsbetrieb was wusste ja und die
frauen waren ja sozusagen die komplizen
seiner sicht aus dieser männer sich
waren ja die komplizen dieses trieb sie
waren ja die verlockung die frauen ja
und deswegen hat er die ganze ambivalenz
die er gegenüber dem willen hat darüber
sprachen wir ja dass diese ambivalenz
die prägt sich nun besonders aus im bild
der frauen die frauen waren
gewissermaßen die des beute objekt des
gierigen will und er konnte den gierigen
willen nicht leiden und er konnte
deswegen auch seine beute objekte nicht
leiden
und so ergibt es so ein ganz komisches
frauenwelt bei ihm der verein
geschlechts trinkt hebelte männliche
intellekt als dann im selben aufsatz
über die weiler wobei noch dazu kommt
dass ich glaube ich wenn man wenn man
dieses ganze rhetorische bimbam daraus
nimmt und ein bisschen säure
wissenschaftlern bleibt auch vielen
tagen bricht vom mann des neunzehnten
jahrhunderts
das muss man schon im hinterkopf
behalten
der letzte heute noch gelesen der
schopenhauer er war kein vorreiter der
emanzipation sondern im achtzehnten
jahrhundert geboren im 19ten
aufgewachsen und mit solchen
vorstellungen behaftet bauer wird
endlich klar das liegt dann aber auch
mit seiner besonderen statur zusammen es
gibt ja es gibt den kopf es gibt die
geschlechtlichkeit die sexualität und
normalerweise gibt es so ein
zwischenbereich das nennen wir die seele
ja also wo die sexualität so erotisiert
das erotik sexualität die erotik ist ja
die zivilisierte form der sexualität ja
bei stockmeyer war diese mittlere ebene
ja das seelische sozusagen das war
ziemlich gering entwickelt die
sexualität war stark und der kopf war
stark aber diese mittlere zone wurden wo
beide seiten gewissermaßen zu halben
preis gehandelt werden verminderte
intellektualität aber an gesteigerte zur
erotik gesteigerte sexualität das war in
dieser in diesem zwischenbereich da war
nicht viel bei ihm das stoßen
gewissermaßen beide dimensionen die
reine sexualität und der reine geist ja
die stoßen gewissermaßen direkt
aufeinander
und so ist auffällig dass schopenhauer
kein richtiges verhältnis zu erotik im
weitesten sinn hat in ihrem buch selber
rehabilitieren dienen da doch auch etwas
das finde ich auch ganz wichtig ein
bisschen muss da schon da gewesen seien
das kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen
aber von der grund figur her ist er ein
mensch der von diesen beiden polen
stärker lebt und nicht von der erotik
bei bei schopenhauer gab es überhaupt
nichts mittleres also das war entweder
funktionieren
sozusagen zum thema machen das seien
gerade zum zärtlicher schopenhauer die
jungs bei ihnen begegnet auch gut so
zärtlich ist ja auch nicht aber es ist
ja so dass die frauen die an gehandelt
hat und die eine frau wäre wohl sehr
lange nachgegangen ist erstaunlich
selbständige und für die damalige zeit
auch relativ konventionelle frauen waren
also weil es schauspielerinnen die die
gar nicht ins gefühl gepasst hätten
das hat mich dann auch darin bestärkt
diese figur dazu anzulegen
diese freundin von schopenhauer dort
auch als eine etwas wildere frau die so
einen die schopenhauer vielleicht noch
am ehesten handeln hätte können
was wahrscheinlich dem schopenhauer dann
auch entgegengekommen wäre weil die auch
auf ihrem distanz geachtet hätte also
eine die ihn ständig am abend das setzt
wohl ich getan bei ihm würde ich gern
noch auf das momentan zu sprechen kommen
der mitleids tätig also schuppen hatte
auch eine ethik verfasst wie bringen wir
dieses element mit rein also in diesen
unbändigen willen da gibt es doch auch
noch eine ethik na ja meine geschoben
hauer
auch da ist ja eigentlich stark weil er
nicht vom sich ausdenken ausgeht sondern
von der elementaren erfahrungen ja und
da sagt er was ist eigentlich die quelle
unserer moralität das kann nicht ein
intellektueller grundsatz sein wie bei
wie bei kann tja das ist viel zu sehr
vom kopf her gedacht sondern es muss
näher an der erfahrung dran sein und da
sagt er dann und da beschreibt er
eigentlich etwas was wir doch kennen
vielleicht nicht immer unter dem mit
intel - mitleid fassen da beschreibt er
diese erfahrung einerseits ist jeder ein
einzelner aber nun darüber sprachen wir
ja ist ja alles will ich erleben in mir
aber er ist auch überall vor allem in
meinen mitmenschen genauso und bis hin
zu den tieren da ist auch drin
das heißt einerseits erlebt man sich wie
eine festung
eine burg als individuum aber ist doch
fleisch vom fleische hat ist doch
verbunden mit dem ganzen und diese
erfahrung dass man das fremde leid mit
eigen leiblicher intensität empfindet
mit empfindet heute wird und empathie
sympathien zu schwacher ausdruck noch
ist ja mit leiden können er sagt diese
art von innerer gefühlter gelebte
solidarität nicht sentimentalität sonder
von gefühlter solidarität das ist
eigentlich die quelle des moralischen
handelns wenn wir denn moralisch handeln
in der regel sagt strotmeier und ich
denke da hatte auch recht ist ja der
moralismus eigentlich nur an
verfeinerten egoismus
er sagt dass es kann auch nötig sein
also eine gesellschaft kann gar nicht
oft auf der mitleid aufbauen dazu spule
die quelle nicht regelmäßig genug ja
sondern die einer gesellschaft muss
natürlich für ihre regelungen
gewissermaßen auf den wechselseitigen
egoismus bauen
ja sie muss zu sagen dass oder auch ein
kollektives einen kollektiven egoismus
bewirtschaften ja aber sagt seien wir
ehrlich mit moral hat das gar nicht so
viel zu tun moralisch sind eigentlich
nur diese quellen und er predigt nicht
moral war er sagt immer ich verwirrt die
dinge untersuchen und ich sagen wie ich
denke wie es ist und das macht seine
mitleid liebig aus gleichzeitig waren ja
schon wichtig die frage demgegenüber
sorgen eigentlich mitleid empfinden in
ihrem buch gibt es diese szene wo er die
sklaven beobachtet und nach
entsprechendes niederschreibt wien das
aufwühlt und in ihrem roman ganz wichtig
der umgang mit tieren
das mitleid erstreckt sich auf jede
kreatur das ist auch wie ein punkt
brachte das indische also
das indische philosophie land wieder mit
rein kommt er sagt dann das geht nach
dem spruch hat war sie nämlich an dass
dies bist du also bevor du anfängst ein
pferd zu schlagen überlege der seite
bewusst dass das was du da schlägt das
bist du selbst bei noch mal kurz zum
mitleid das ist auch so ein etwas
irreführende begriff jährlich wieder
pessimismus
es ist wirklich ein gemeint ein
allumfassendes mit empfinden für die
andere kreatur und nicht wie man das
heute er versteht sein so ein bisschen
so ein abfall und finden ja dieses
gefühl das ist ein
das ist einem dass es einem anderen
vielleicht noch schlechter geht als mir
selbst also das ist kein keine keine
danach lässiges gefühl vielleicht auch
wichtig daran zu erinnern also eher
mitleid ist nicht in seinem verständnis
eine norm sondern ist eher andersrum
eigentlich empfinden wir mitleid immer
wieder wir entwickeln er ein ganzes
system um diese gefühle nicht zuzulassen
und wenn jörg maurer da ein enorm
entwickelt dann allenfalls die das
verhindern zu verhindern
also diese diese einladung nicht so
aktiv zu betreiben ja das ist anders es
nicht also seid bitte schön mitleidig
sondern hört auf euch dagegen zu werden
er so seinen seinen leitspruch wird
überhaupt es einen da gibt es ist
einfach schade niemandem also kein
großer kategorischer imperativ mit
großem getöse sondern schadet niemandem
fertig jetzt die beide haben große
bücher geschrieben über schopenhauer sie
haben fiktion geschaffen sich eine
biografie gucken jungs dieses verhältnis
noch ein bisschen an wenn ich ihr buch
lese dann hatte ich immer so ein
bisschen das gefühl da kommt sehr viel
über biografie und sehr viel über die
philosophie von schopenhauer
wie hängen diese beiden dinge
und ich zusammen war ganz generell
gesprochen also würden sie sagen das
denken eines philosophen ist maßgeblich
geprägt durch sein erleben durch seine
biografie
naja es ist es wächst aus dem leben
heraus und ist eine mal ganz aus der
förster distanz gesehen ist ein stück
gesteigertes leben in meiner sicht und
wirkt wieder auf das leben zurück es
kommt aus dem individuellen leben und
wirkt wieder da raus zu darauf zurück
ich will nur sagen dass überhaupt bei
meinem biographien ich versuche zu einen
die den biografisch muss zu vermeiden
biografisch muss ist in meinem
verständnis und versucht so den zu
reduzieren
auf irgendwelche fügt an wir mal
frühkindlichen deformationen oder usw
der biografisch muss ist diese
kammerdiener perspektive in
demokratischen zeiten ist das besonders
beliebt so dem sinne den kriegen wir
auch noch runter der ist doch so wie wir
alle ja man hat man ist nicht befreundet
mit mit wirklich eminenten figuren dann
hat man gar nicht so gerne man will die
immer runter ziehen ja und da bietet
sich der biografisch muss an und das
will ich nicht und wenn mir jemand
biografisch muss vorwirft dann finde ich
das als eine beleidigung weil ich das
eben nicht möchte aber natürlich das
spannende ist dass philosophie sind ist
nämlich kategorien mit zwei beinen ja
sondern dass das das hängt ist mit der
ganzen lebens materie verwachsen die
philosophie und das wieder
herauszubringen das ist ein aufregendes
unternehmen das war eigentlich fast
schon philosophische position ihrer
seite
man könnte ja sagen naja philosophie da
geht es darum die wahrheit zu suchen und
zu finden
wenn sie nun sagen dass es zur wurzel
mit dem leben mit dem lebensalter
lebenserfahrungen des philosophen dann
ist die wahrheit vielleicht ein bisschen
brüchiger naja wir was sie was sie nun
absolut ist wissen wir sowieso nicht es
gibt eigentlich wir gucken mit
abermillionen augen gucken wir auf die
wirklichkeit und es gibt sehr sehr viele
perspektiven und es gibt aber natürlich
auch torheiten das gibt auch es ist
nicht alles gleichgültig
ja es ist es gibt schon es gibt schon
entwürfe philosophische entwürfe wo man
das im einzelnen schwer begründbare
gefühl hat ja der ist ziemlich oder die
ist ziemlich dicht dran
dazu muss man nicht der besitzer einer
absoluten wahrheit sein
man muss nur ein bisschen sensibel sein
sie haben sich ganz bewusst für sektion
entschieden sie schreiben einen roman
über schopenhauer wie viel ware oder
richtiger wirklicher schopenhauer steckt
in diesem buch schwer zu sagen weil es
weiß ich habe noch keine einheit oder
keinen kein maßeinheit dafür gefunden
wie man das bemessen wollte also es ist
viel schöner recherchiert viele fakten
sind drin
aber natürlich gibt es auch lücken und
ich habe versucht diese lücken
aufzufüllen dass er halbwegs plausibel
sind oder zumindest für die geschichte
passen ich damit dem schoppenhauer immer
gerecht werde
spielt dann ab einem bestimmten punkt
auch schon keine rolle mehr nennen das
ist wie gesagt keine biografie sogar
einen roman
wobei natürlich keine figuren stehen
soll jetzt wirklich völlig konträr zu
dem wäre was man was man vom shoppen
arbeit zu wissen glaubt obwohl dieses
ist ja der junge schopenhauer und das
allgemeine bild bestimmte alte schuppen
aber mit all den klischees die man kennt
oder nicht kennt insofern ist er doch
vielleicht wieder neu jetzt haben wir
verschiedentlich schon gehört dass
schopenhauer zu seiner zeit mühe hatte
sozusagen sich zu etablieren erst im
alter dann berühmt wurde gelesen wurde
besucht wurde
dies ist denn heute was ist geblieben
vom schuppen habe ja also ich finde es
ist geblieben erstens mal geblieben ein
philosoph der einen überwältigenden stil
schreibt
das ist einer der mit nietzsche
vielleicht einer der an das beste
deutsch wo man ein bisschen reines
sprachliche vergnügen auch und da wir ja
auch immer wieder mit sprachmüll
zugemüllt werden ja es ist immer wieder
gut einfach mal wieder ein paar sätze
strotmeier zu leben also schopenhauer
das berührt schopenhauer als philosophie
künstler ja und die sind sowieso immer
aktuell da kann man man kann ihr leben
und da kann man nie gelesen auch wenn
man die themen im einzelnen vielleicht
gar nicht teilt es ist ein philosophie
künstler zweiter
ja das kam jetzt zur sprache ich denke
dass schopenhauers biologische wende in
der philosophie
die hält an jugendliche bringen wir wir
sind voll dabei
jetzt biologisch auf den menschen
zugucken das ist bloß leider gucken wir
unter dem einfluss der modernen
naturwissenschaften gucken wir immer
mehr biologistisch und das ist wieder
was anderes denn biologistisch
unterbietet den menschen unter bietet
vor allem dasjenige was dann
schopenhauer unter seiner verneinung
philosophie beschrieben hat das ist
spiegel räume gibt wie wir mit unserer
eigenen biologie umgehen können ja das
selber gewissermaßen wir sind eine
funktion der biologie aber in seiner
willens verneinung da zeigt er doch auf
einmal auch dass es auch optionen gibt
gegen die trieb natur etwas noch
auszurichten
und das ist einfach gesprochen ein stück
freiheit und der biologismus erklärt die
freiheit weg und das ist eine dummheit
ja weil jeder biologisch benutzt seine
freiheit um die freiheit weg zu erklären
ja und in deswegen ist schob aus
aktualität besteht in dieser
unnachahmlichen verbindung zwischen
biologischer wende von von der biologie
her den menschen zu begreifen und
zugleich eine
sophie der askese des verzichtes kurzum
der freiheits möglichkeit zu entwickeln
das finde ich ganz großartig so zu sagen
wie der mensch den menschen selbst
austrickst mit beschrieben
das müssen sie ein bisschen erläutern
wie der mensch dem menschen auftritt ja
mit seinen eigenen möglichkeiten aber
dass ich es auch übersteigen dabei ist
ja unser fans gerade beschrieben hat das
ist nun haben sie aber doch im
klappentext sozusagen zum tausch zu der
taschenbuchausgabe steht schopenhauer
ist kein champion der akademischen
philosophie
das meinten sie wahrscheinlich dann mehr
einfach auf die diese zeit gezogen das
erlebte ja natürlich ich jetzt eine
große figur auch in der akademischen
philosophie es gibt nur das was ihm
sozusagen den den umgang etwas erschwert
auch immer noch in der in den in der
universität ist dass schopenhauer so
klar ist also man beschäftigt sich
unablässig mit kant und hegel warum weil
die ihm zum teil dermaßen undeutlich
sind ja das ist unendlich viel zu
interpretieren gibt ja da habe man muss
diese entwicklung haben die wunderbare
klarheit ja und und dass man hat ja
manchmal geradezu lädt ein doch das
stört die klarheit stört ja das ist man
kann da nicht so viele forschungsstellen
und drittmittel eintreiben ja also man
es gibt da nicht so viel zu
interpretieren im sinne dass das die
dinge da unklar wären ja nein es man
kann mit unglaublich viel anfangen und
man kann eben mit allen möglichen
verknüpfen
aber in sich selber ist ja klar und er
ruht wie so eine kugel aus dem
neunzehnten jahrhundert rundum klar und
deutlich und präzise und jeder weiß
eigentlich was er was er sagt und was er
meint wenn man ein paar
missverständnisse beseitigt ja und was
tun da die armen universitäten ja ende
da durchschlagen
vielleicht letzte frage haben sie beide
wenn jemand gerne schopenhauer lesen
möchte im originalton was wäre zu lesen
was würden sie empfehlen herrn
poschenrieder
ich glaube ich finde schon die
aphorismen zur lebensweisheit empfehlen
oder das den anfang von der ersten
vorstellung die ersten paar kapitel kann
man durchaus betrachten wenn man sich
dann mit der philosophie nicht weiter
beschäftigen möchte dann kann man das
ganze werk auch eigentlich als roman
lesen mit vier abschnitten aus vier
perspektiven erzählt
das ist die geschichte eines
protagonisten der heißt wille am anfang
steht dann noch ein bisschen im dunkeln
dann kommt da raus dann wird er von
einer anderen seite geschrieben
damit spart man sich die einzelheiten
was sie was die vorgänger betrifft was
das philosophische fachvokabular
betrifft habe man kann es auch so lesen
naja also gerade denn anfangen will dann
als wille und vorstellung auch das ende
sie zitieren dass sie auch in ihrem buch
grandios ein buch das mit dem nichts
endet ja vom feinsten aber dann würde
ich auch sagen einen kurzen text in den
park wo er über den lärm schreibt und da
findet man die wunderbare beobachtung
dass die menschen umso also dass jemand
umso mehr lärm macht je weniger er im
kopf hat umso lauter umso dümmer ja und
das ist in unserer um in einer umwelt
der die die wir haben eine eine lärm
verschmutzung in deutschland und wir
glauben die selbstinszenierung mit field
mit viel tamtam das sei was und da wird
man bei schopenhauer wunderbar belehrt
und das sind nur vier seiten die
empfehle ich jedem der so ähnlich
empfindet wie ich das gerade formuliert
hat also mit einem flat war dafür die
modernen schopenhauer ist ich würde
gerne ihnen noch lange zuhören leider
sind die am ende der sendung angegangen
angelangt der safranski hat
poschenrieder ich bedanke mich ganz
herzlich
[Musik]